مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
اصدرت مجله
او نشره اخبار عن رغبه ملاك نادي ليفربول
ولا هي شركه اف اس جي بقياده جون هنري
برغبه الاداره بربما عرض النادي للبيع
وفتح الباب امام الراغبين في شراء هذا
النادي بعد تجربه تشيلسي وتجربه شراء عدد
من المستثمرين على راسا توب بويلي هذا
النادي من الروسيه
لنبدا القصه من الاول ولا تعرفوا التفاصيل
من البدايه
اجى جون هنري بقياده شركه اف اس جي لكان
الى اسم ثاني في ذلك الوقت واشترى نادي
ليفربول في اكتوبر من عام 2010
وكانت قيمه نادي في ذلك الوقت تقريبا
حوالي اكثر بشوي من 300 مليون دولار
خلال الفتره ما بين 2010 و 2020 نجح نادي
ليفربول بقياده اف اس جي بي الفوز بلقب
دوري ابطال اوروبا عام 2019 تحقيق لقب
الدوري الانجليزي بعد غياب اكثر من 30
عاما عام 2020 وحقق طبعا القاب اخرى من
ضمن كاس الاتحاد الانجليزي وكاس الرابطه
ووصل لنهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا في ثلاث
مناسبات وخسر مرتين وحقق اللقب مره
هذه الحقبه الناجحه كان بالتاكيد اساسا
اداره جيده ولكن ايضا اختيار مناسب للمدرب
واللي هو الالماني يورجن كلوب واللي
بالمناسبه راح نرجع نحكي هل سيستمر يورجن
كلوب مع الاداره الجديده بحال تنباع
النادي ولا انه راح يفكر يطلع مباشره
بنهايه فتره
خلال هذه الفتره قيمه ليفربول اصبحت عاليه
جدا جدا جدا واصبح يحتل المركز الرابع في
قائمه اغنى او اغلى الانديه حول العالم
ليفربول بيجيء بعد مانشستر يونايتد وبعد
ريال مدريد وبعد برشلونه في الترتيب
وقيمته يقال انه هي تبلغ وفقا لفوق طبعا
ما يقارب اربعه مليار دولار او اكثر من
اربعه مليار دولار يعني اشتروا ب 300
مليون وراح يبيعوه باربعه مليار دولار
طبعا خلال هذه الفتره كان في مصاريف كبيره
على تجديد على صفقات على غيرها من الامور
المستثمرين الامريكان
اخوها بالنادي بعد ما كان على وشك
الانهيار مع الاداره لسبقه واللي كانت
ايضا امريكيه ولكنها اوصلت نادي الى مكان
سيء جدا وتم التصويت على تنحيتها جانبا من
قبل مجلس الاداره ذلك الان الفكره
المطروحه هي انه شو المستقبل او كيف ممكن
يتعامل ليفربول مع هذا التغير المحتمل اف
اس جي لما تم سؤال عن الموضوع كان جوابه
مبهمه شويه مش واضح يعني سالوها قالوا لها
هل فعلا ترغبين في بيع هذا النادي قالت
الشركه في بيان نحن نفتح المجال امام
الشير هولدرز الراغبين في المساهمه في هذا
النادي في ان يقوموا بذلك ولكن ما علقت
بشكل مباشر ابدا ابدا على موضوع ارض
النادي للبيع
الان السؤال الاخر هو ليش بهذا التوقيت
بهذا التوقيت لانه ببساطه وبنحكي بكل
صراحه ب 2020 قررت انديه ريال مدريد
برشلونه وبعض الانديه الانجليزيه من ضمن
ليفربول بالاضافه الى يوفنتوس وميلان
وانتر في ايطاليا
للخروج على الاتحاد الاوروبي
وانشاء ما كان يسمى في ذلك الوقت السوق
فكره السوبر لينك كانت فكره جذابه جدا
بالنسبه لرؤساء الانديه وخصوصا بالنسبه
الي كان شايف فيها فرصه للجنه المزيد من
الاموال والارباح ولكن مثلنا نعرف انه هاي
الفكره قبلت برفض كبير من جانب الجماهير
وخصوصا جماهير ليفربول اللي اجبر انه يطلع
بفيديو بعد ذلك ويعتذر على فكره السوبر
ليك ويقول انهم ما كنت عارف شو الموضوع
بالضبط
شايف انه موضوع تحقيق ارباح اضافيه او
ربما زياده قيمه هذا النادي ماليا طبعا
صارت صعبه شويه لانه النادي حاليا في
مرحله تراجع مستوى وقد تؤدي هذه المرحله
الى مرحله تراجع دائم وبالتالي قيمه
النادي ممكن انه هي يعني على المدى البعيد
تنزل شويه ويصير في خسائر فهو شايف ان
الوقت هنا الحالي هو الوقت المناسب للقيام
بهذه الخطوه وخصوصا بعد تجربه تشيلسي مع
تود بويلي وغيره من المستثمرين السؤال
الثاني او الثالث اللي ممكن ينسى في هذا
الاطار هو هل سيستمر يورجن كلوب ولا لا
يرجى كلوب علاقته جيد جدا مع رئيس النادي
اللي هو مش جون هنري واحد حتى جون هنري هو
مش رئيس النادي هو رئيس الشركه رئيس
fsg وعلاقته معه قويه جدا وفي اتصال كما
يقال يومي بينهم وفي تواصل دائما لذلك من
المتوقع ان يورجن كلوب بحال اف اس جي قررت
انه هي تبيع ليفربول انه يورجن كلوب نهايه
عقده ب 24 راح يغادر للفريق وراح يدور على
تجربه جديده ويتعامل مع اداره جديده خارج
صغار
هذا طبعا مجرد توقع ولكن ما حدا بيعرف شو
ممكن يصير على المدى البعيد بكل الاحوال
ليفربول الان في مرحله يبدو انه راح يتحول
فيها الى الى مرحله انتقاليه او الى وضع
انتقالي من الذي سيشتري هل فعلا سيبيع هذه
الامور متروك للايام القادمه خلينا نشوف
هذا الامر كيف رح يكون له تاثير على
مستقبل الفريق كيف راح يكون تاثيره على
اللاعبين وخصوصا الكبار في هذا الفريق في
قادم الايام او الاشهر على اقصى تقديم هذا
كان كل شيء بحلقه لهم بعض الصافي الى ان
نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل